it would appear that a move is being
made right now to suppress or even get
Rumble banned at the beginning is that
advertisers are pulling off of Rumble
because Rumble refuses to shut down
Russell Brand now most of you are aware
if you if you track the show over the
past week UK Parliament actually sent
letters to various social media networks
and television networks effectively
demanding that Russell Russell Brand's
deals be yanked or his content get
pulled now we are seeing big Brands like
Burger King and hellofresh pull their
ads off of Rumble sparking calls for
another boycott and I gotta be honest
I've been boycotting Burger King for a
long time and it's not political it's
just that their food is trash so you
know there's that we got a bunch of
other stories too I mean the crazy news
is that U.S Abrams Tanks have arrived in
Ukraine oh boy
and now a report from CBS news shows
that the U.S taxpayer is footing the
bill for Ukrainian small businesses
that's right we're not just funding the
war we're funding the lives of your
everyday Ukraine and hey man I like
Ukraine I Ukrainian people but I don't
know why our tax tax dollars are going
to paying for their businesses that
makes no sense well this might make
sense I guess in that context Canadian
Parliament cheered and clapped for an
actual Nazi yeah and now they're saying
they're all embarrassed but this is how
depraved their cult zealotry in support
of Ukraine has become to the point where
they will give a standing ovation to a
Nazi because he's Ukrainian that's nuts
we'll talk about that plus Washington
Post is quite concerned their own poll
shows Donald Trump beating Joe Biden by
10 points whoops they're saying no no
please it's just an outlier despite the
fact that Trump is leading in aggregate
across the board in all these different
polls yeah
we'll get into all that before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com click timcast irlx Miami and
pick up your tickets while you still can
we're about to just about two weeks week
and a half out from our Miami event
October 6th 6 p.m 10 30 p.m it's gonna
be amazing we've got Patrick Bet David
James O'Keefe Matt Gates it'll be me
lukerkowski Ian Crossland we're gonna
have a bunch of special guests Alex
Stein will be doing an opening set we've
got a pre-show we got an after show it's
going to be a whole lot of fun we hope
to see you there a bunch of free stuff
for everybody who attends and uh really
pick up your tickets now we uh we hope
to see you there's gonna be a meet and
greet for timcast.com elite members at 3
P.M that day so if you want to be a
member click join us at timcast.com sign
up and you'll get access to the Discord
server the timcast members Community
hangout where there is a pre-show
everyone's talking to each other and
after dark show after we wrap up for the
night all of our members keep the
conversation going and we will host at
10 pm and uncensored members only show
that you can come hang out at and even
submit questions potentially call into
the show and talk to us and our guests
so go to timcast.com sign up don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more we
got Patriot J what up man thank you for
having me absolutely who are you what do
you do uh man I'm a part-time rap artist
criminal defense attorney in Los Angeles
political reporter for Breitbart I do a
little bit of everything here and there
right on well thanks for hanging out
it's gonna be fun we also got Andy no
he's in town hi Tim thanks for having me
back absolutely who are you what do you
do I am a journalist a senior editor at
the post millennial I'm probably most uh
well known for my reporting on antifa
right on and uh recently there was uh
something happened we'll talk about this
too a member of the democratic party
sent a terroristic threat to shut down
one of your events or something like
that yeah so I'm in the US on this trip
because on on Friday uh September 22nd I
um was invited to speak by The Common
Sense Society in Richmond Virginia uh an
event put on by the Virginia Council and
uh it took the third venue for me to
actually speak the first one was the uh
Commonwealth club which is a gentleman's
club and they gave in to a council
campaign by The Extreme as far last a
gentleman's club yes that's right like a
strip club no like a sexual club right
sorry I forgot yeah that's the American
colloquialism uh social club for oh okay
so um they canceled
um shame on them and
then the second was the uh a Marriott
Hotel in in Richmond and on the day of
they canceled and all it took for the
mini cave was just for uh these
agitators to call in there was they put
out the script with all these lies
saying that I was a Neo-Nazi this is a
Neo-Nazi event and armed Nazis was
coming and Marriott corporate canceled
and
um fortunately we were able to speak at
a community center in the end and there
were about 200 people who came and
there were a lot of times to shut it
down and there was a person
um who's a leader in the official
Democrat Party group in Richmond uh
Jimmy Lee Jimmy Lee Jarvis who posted
um uh a picture on social media saying
that he was going to the andigo event
and the picture was of an individual
holding up a box of dynamite
wow well we'll talk about that in a
whole lot more so thanks for hanging out
man glad to see that you're okay and the
event went off somehow but we got Hannah
clear hang out as well hey I'm Hannah
Cliff brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm so excited to be here
with this West Coast West Coast
contingent searches here too finally
I am back uh thanks Carter and thanks
Kellen for taking care of this while I
was out I'm excited to meet you guys
both let's get started Tim all right
here's the first story from the New York
Post
Burger King faces boycott after yanking
ads from Rumble over Russell Brand
accusations there's so much crammed into
this headline Russell Brand accusations
Rumble defends it berking boycotts man
that's like each of those things are our
big story is just piled on top of each
other they say though Burger King hasn't
publicly stated why it recently removed
its adverts on the popular site just as
other brands like Asos and hellofresh
recently did social media users have
questioned the timing of the move which
came just one week after brand came
under Fire the Whopper House has since
been bashed for pulling its ads from the
self-proclaimed Free Speech platform
before bran has actually been convicted
Burger King has pulled its head for
Mumble because the Free Speech platform
refuses to play judge jury and
executioner of Russell Brand after the
UK Governor demanded the platform
demonetize him UK governor who's that is
that a reference to somebody I'm not
familiar with that position in the UK I
know as a UK Parliament Member of
Parliament right yeah I think that's
probably a typo it was a member of
parliament yeah Member of Parliament
sent a letter out to all these different
Networks reminder Brad has not been
convicted of a single crime boycott
Burger King they hate free speech and
due process and their food is poison
anyways stop eating it I just want to
pause and say if you've been eating
Burger King for any reason
please don't I think Burger King is just
awful but that's just my opinion I mean
I'm not gonna besmirched the good name
of Burger King I guess is this Charlie
Kirk saying it's poison I wonder what
the the the legalities on that calling
it poison I think that's like I don't
know if you can say that but I guess
it's an opinion statement I think Burger
King is unhealthy and I I'd be I think
it's very would be very funny if Burger
King started suing people for claiming
their food is bad for you because it is
bad for you you know they're onion rings
I don't even know what their onion rings
are I gotta guess I think their onion
rings are potatoes no for real have you
ever had Burger King onion rings like
years ago I'm pretty sure it's I well in
my opinion it does not it's not an onion
like it's it's some kind of mashed
something or other they cut into a ring
yeah just not good anyway yeah here we
go this is the next store we have from
the guardian firms pull ads from Rumble
platform over Russell Brand videos so
it's Burger King Asos and hellofresh
have removed these ads and now we're
getting people calling for a boycott of
these companies and this is uh in a
public statement post on the next Rumble
called the letter disturbing because the
government came out
so basically this is where we're at I
think what we're seeing here is actually
a move to begin to remove Rumble in the
story from the Sun they say I'm an
online expert Russell Brand's Refuge
platform Rumble may be forced offline
under new Internet safety laws
Rumble may go the uh parlor route what
do you guys think
I mean I think Russell Brand is
obviously being treated completely
unfairly uh you know he doesn't even
have a way to defend himself from these
allegations because there's it hasn't
nothing has been filed in a court of law
so other than
um Rumble support Rumble saying
basically you don't need to leave our
platform he doesn't have a lot of
recourse here uh and that's that's a
bizarre position to put in I mean what
is he going to do well the question is
well are they targeting Rumble is are
they going to go after Rumble and try
and get Rumble taken down advertisers
pulling off the entirety of the platform
because Russell Brand is on it how does
that make sense
I think we need to figure out some sort
of way for people to just fund these
websites I I'm sure they're I'm not
familiar with Rumble but I'm sure that
they have subscriptions or things like
that but really really need to get back
to like users funding this because the
advertisers have so much power
true but the advertisers on platforms
like YouTube gave birth to the
influencer ecosphere it's a whole
generation of media that's really
disruptive I mean as much as you know
podcasts and alternative news really
it's the influencer web that drives
these things which for the most part is
predominantly funded by advertisers it
seems unfair that you know people
looking to have an alternative to
YouTube would not be able to participate
in
standard retail advertising dollars I
mean not that you should buy everything
in influencer sells on the other hand
there in addition to unpersoning Russell
Brand there's an attempt to unplatform
rumble itself I buy a lot of stuff off
Instagram basically if Instagram shows
it to me I'm buying it because because
you know they're ripping through my
private data and the computer out the
algorithms know you better than you
better than you know yourself right and
so then you get this ad for like I don't
know this this UFO thing I got I got an
ad on Instagram for it and I was like I
must buy this and so I did and then they
added that shop feature to make it
easier creepy we really need to commend
uh Rumble for not giving in to the
Prussia campaigns that they're probably
feeling from every direction right now
um YouTube should be condemned I think
is the strongest terms for demonetizing
Russell Brand based on
um accusations in the media where he has
really no recourse or ability to respond
other than through the media space
um and the BBC has been pressured into
removing old content that features brand
so he's losing royalties from there with
that said I I do want to caveat that I
think for all the people that that came
out have come out immediately in defense
of of Mr brand I I'm I'm just concerned
that the the backlash against
um I believe all women is is becoming
now the flip side of believe no women
and I I actually think that the Sunday
Times investigation was very thorough
and I think the allegations are credible
with that said though they are Anonymous
and they're placed entirely in the space
of a media PR battle
uh through a civil lawsuit and no
charges have been filed in the criminal
space so
for a man now
um who's having his entire career
unravel in a matter of hours it's this
is a it's a deep Injustice and it feels
I yeah I I don't find them credible I I
don't no I mean first I'll defer to you
I mean uh I've only have I only I've
only read the articles about them right
but my issue is if Russell Brand has a
relationship with someone no no not
Universal brand if a man and a woman
have a relationship and they argue with
each other and they fight
you can say that you know 20 years later
oh look here's here's text messages
showing them fighting him saying will
you apologize I know I acted poorly last
night and the Assa the assumptions you
can make based off of of
a 20 year old story
so this there's a text message between
Russell and this woman the reason why I
view this stuff as
I I don't I don't know uh not worthy of
news in my opinion is for one the media
absolutely loved everything he was doing
all that time ago people change whatever
if the argument is he shouldn't do this
well he's not doing it now okay so it's
been 20 years the issue I have is let's
say you Andy got into a fight with
someone and you texted them saying it
was really inappropriate what you did
last night I had demand an apology I
can't believe you would do that to me
and what happened he stiffed you on a
bill at a bar
and then it says like look when I tell
you this is how it's going down you
can't you can't do this to me I am
furious and this I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry and then later 20 years you're
like oh that text uh that was rape and
it's like no no wait hold on that text
is about something totally different
it's 20 years later what do you do the
problem I have with these accusations 20
years on is that
you can take a legitimate relationship
and then just say 20 years later oh that
was not consensual what how do you even
prove that I'm not I'm not saying like
there are challenges in the law but the
weirdest thing about how the law is
handled today is that when it comes to
murder there are cold cases where
there's a person who's been suspected of
the murder and we're like What do we do
and then people are like I don't know I
think he might be the murderer but we
really don't know but then when it comes
to issues like this it's like destroy
his life entirely because of anonymous
accusations
there's that the police are just now
opening investigation so
I suppose my point is it is almost
impossible for accusations this this far
this this old to be credible I don't
know what you do to make them credible
that being said
they there can be new evidence I'm sure
things can emerge was like a video
Russell made of himself where he's like
I can't believe that I actually did that
to those women last night it's true blah
blah it's from 20 years ago you're like
oh wow there's evidence evidence exists
for the time being they've only just
started an investigation so it's like
I'm sure man I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't call it credible and
actually I would I would at this point I
agree with you when you say it shouldn't
be believe no women it's true
but we're talking about believe all
women is supposed to be a woman goes to
the police the next day or maybe within
a week and you know she's traumatized
she's not to do and then she makes
accusation we say okay we will believe
that we will operate under the
assumption the accusation is true and
correct and investigate it's not
supposed to be that 20 years later
someone comes out to the to the news in
the press and says oh that famous
celebrity yeah he did a bad thing to me
and then advertisers poll ads off a
platform because he's on that platform
none of this makes sense why would the
UK government try to get Russell Brand
banned that makes no sense that makes
the claims it strikes their credibility
outright like for sure you can make the
argument that the the Member of
Parliament was just exploiting a crisis
situation for political gain but it just
I just don't see it
um well
I think the actions of these third
parties who are now
politicians
um activist groups online activists I
think their actions shouldn't
necessarily
um affect the credibility of those who
have come forward
um these are third parties that have
their own ulterior motives the the MP
will have her own reasons to try to
elevate her name and profile on the
process through these type of actions as
well as other individuals who have um
Place pressure to try to destroy
um the career of Russell Brand is just
I think um
uh you know I've been through
um I've been the the victim in
um or I've I've been through a trial a
criminal trial where I was a witness who
testified uh and made allegations in a
criminal matter before and that process
I think has
it helped me understand potentially why
some victims don't go forward uh the
process of
um being cross-examined and gaslit and
reliving over and over a really
traumatic experience is it really
destroys you and that then kind of
opened my eyes to why I kind of
understand why some women for the first
time it made me understand perhaps why
some people don't immediately go to law
enforcement however that that doesn't
mean that I support them that decades
later years later then they go
anonymously to the Press yeah I got a
bad I don't care I I I don't play to
this emotional argument of oh it's so
hard and it's so emotional it you know
it was very difficult for people to do
this they say oh victims have a hard
time that sucks sorry have a nice day
the justice system is not supposed to be
your feelings are hurt so we're going to
destroy a man's life over it the justice
system is yes we recognize their
hardships we want to to seek the best
outcomes for justice that means if there
is a guy who is abusing women in large
numbers then definitely we're going to
try and solve for that problem however
if you as the victim are unable to
provide evidence and testimony in a
meaningful matter and with in in in a
Time appropriate manner then that's it
the legal system is not supposed to be
bent because some people have hurt
feelings I I will I do not accept that I
mean that's the UK I can't speak for
London I can say for the United States I
absolutely reject the idea that we would
have to put someone's freedom and
liberty at risk to protect the feelings
of another person because oh they felt
bad sorry you need to have evidence it
needs to be proven Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt and what we're seeing now is in
line with so many other BS moments
throughout the past couple of decades or
a decade or so where people have been
falsely accused and uh Julian Assange a
great example the media lied about
everything they use it to destroy his
life they didn't they didn't just fire
him they locked him up and they have him
locked up to this day despite the fact
we know the accusations that were made
were completely untrue so when you get
at Jeffrey Epstein who gets away with it
and gets protection from the media and
the press and then later it's like
whoops all of that was true forgive me
if I don't believe you when you go after
a Julian Assange and you you're you're
ignoring the people on your side and
you're targeting the people who are not
on your side all all I see right here is
when when multiple agencies pull off
Rumble that's that that the Occam's
razor suggests a coordinated effort to
do so when Alex Jones got banned and I
think it was was it 2018 or was it 2019
2018. 2018. all the networks did at the
same time there's an argument to be made
that they were just waiting for uh you
know one you know Twitter is like as
soon as any other company makes a move
we'll do it too or
you likely have a scenario where there
was some political agenda in the
instance of Alex Jones we don't know
definitively but in the instance of
Russell Brand we know for a fact the UK
government solicited networks and and
platforms to remove Russell Brand so why
are these ads now being pulled from
Rumble likely because the same people in
the UK government are now targeting
anybody who's sponsoring Rumble I don't
think it's as simple as to say a couple
activists called Burger King and said oh
you know you guys are running ads on
Rumble now it's more like a national
security letter gets sent out saying you
will do this now or else or maybe they
don't need it maybe a member of
parliament contacts your your head of
legal office with a Shakedown letter and
Burger King's like listen we do not need
Rumble 44 million users it's not worth a
permitting headache with the UK UK
government we're generating hundreds of
millions of dollars out of the UK let's
just let it go I don't know is Burger
King in the UK they're in the UK right I
don't think they make that much money
but that's that's my point if if right
now it's come to the point where you
have four women
who for whatever reason did not
you know come out with these allegations
and it's now 20 plus years later 10 or
20 years later I'm just like
you don't prove it that's all that
matters right you need proof do you have
a take as a criminal defense attorney
yeah I mean Tim's right you need proof
you have to meet a certain burden of
proof uh it's really hard to believe
women 20 years after the fact so these
situations do occur I would encourage
individuals who are victims to report it
as soon as possible rather than waiting
decades down the line and you notice it
always happens when they're in the
spotlight for something or when they're
leaning on the right side because none
of these allegations were ever brought
when Russell Brand was like a darling of
the corporate media it was totally fine
nobody said anything now he's more
independent now you see them trying to
come after him and it just seems very
coordinated right they didn't say
anything when he made married Katy Perry
oh yeah yeah why does the media care how
come the media did not care about
Epstein in fact they covered up for him
but they care so much about Russell
Brand I don't buy it not for one second
they all of a sudden care about Russell
Brand they all of a sudden need to have
the ads pulled they all of a sudden are
realizing his shows have to get pulled
off the BBC Channel 4 and YouTube or
whatever
what
I don't buy it sorry have a nice day
Epstein they knew Epstein had been
charged and well I think it was like in
the 2000s they knew what he was doing he
got a sweetheart deal and was let go
so so where was the media on this one
now you can argue that Epstein was
blackmailing powerful individuals okay
where was the media because this Expose
and Russell Brand is the Sunday Times
it's channel four all of a sudden one
day
somebody at these networks they're just
like you know I'm really concerned about
Russell Brand I'm gonna go dig around
for 20 year old accusations
what someone started so you have to
understand this someone started some
journalist decided to start soliciting
past relationships of Russell Brand to
to and ask them about issues of
impropriety why
no I mean Pharrell look if he was doing
these things that's bad for sure but
it's a weird thing for the media to
immediately want to pick up especially
when it's coming from from corporate
narrative establishment government media
sources quite literally
so
it seems weird and he's in an impossible
position because there's nothing going
on in court right so he could file let's
say a defamation suit maybe against
these Anonymous people but then he is
adding to this narrative that he is the
aggressor right he's going after these
theoretical victims who aren't even
being named and therefore he's trying to
get lots of money on them like there's
no good luck for him in this scenario I
get what you're saying I think I agree I
think it is complicated for a lot of
people to decide to go through the trial
process I don't think cross-examination
is easy uh but the fact that this was
solicited from a reporter is so strange
yeah I mean
what what me too I think has done is
it's it's giving an excuse It's in many
ways how she discourage victims to
um to speak out whenever when they want
and to who they want like the media
rather than
to law enforcement I think law
enforcement in
reporting is so key for victims to get
Justice when you I mean when you wait so
many years and statues limitations
policy memories is blurry evidence is
lost and destroyed
it's just yeah the metoo has been more
about I think
um
uh giving space for people to tell these
stories where they can actually never be
falsifiable and that's you know there's
and in that case you can never even wait
for a due process to play out I see a
lot of people responding like SunTrust
response on social media we should uh
withdraw withhold judgment and wait for
just uh this process to play out but
there is no process playing out so it's
um you know so right I have criticisms
uh you know going so many directions
here I reject all of the uh accusations
and allegations against Russell Brand
all right
I mean it's it's a pattern in but one of
the went to Rape Crisis under at the
time and and considering the political
state of this country considering the
actions being taken against them
considering the motivations of the press
sure but I won't give the benefit of the
doubt sorry not happening it's just
there there's there it's there are so
many bad people and criminals who are
getting away with everything that what
we end up seeing is law enforcement
choose to go after certain people when
it benefits them politically that's the
nature of the West today so when I see
20 year old accusations it's Brett
Kavanaugh all over again sorry don't
care at all you want to investigate you
want to prove it by all means please do
so you prove it in a court fine I get it
but now does anyone actually even
believe these courts you got Donald
Trump and that story that woman in New
York that he went to that department
store Carol Eugene yeah right what was
the department store uh Bergdorf
Goodman's right yeah Goodman's and it's
the busiest place with the most famous
man arguably in the city nobody owns the
hotel next door nobody noticed Donald
Trump with no security going in the
second floor I think it was and and then
and then a New York jury finds Donald
Trump accountable liable for for this
this assault or something sexual assault
yeah that's insane that's insane so by
so sure fine still don't care I don't
care I think the silver weaponization of
it is just so so thick and so intense
I'm giving no one the benefit of the
doubt I think the Silver Lining from the
Russell Brand Story is that people who
care about free speech and due process
are actually standing up and they're
boycotting these companies who are
pulling uh pulling funds from Rumble
advertising I think it's really good to
see the conservative boycotts that have
been happening all year uh it finally
feels like we're trying to make our
voices heard yeah yeah see the issue is
every single time
something happens
or I shouldn't say every single time but
typically there have been major
political moments over the past several
years and you get conservatives
Libertarians and post-liberals all
trying to do the reasonable thing
okay like you said oh we'll hear this
one out and what happens bunk turns out
to be nonsense
I remember uh when George Floyd The
George Floyd video came out and we all
were like yeah that video is bad like
that should not have gone down that way
and then you you get the body camera
footage and learn a lot more about
what's really happening and now you're
like okay so it's it's tragic but
it's a bit different than the way they
put it the original video of George
Floyd is a guy being he's on the ground
and they're kneeling on his neck and he
dies and it's like whoa then you learn
the dude was chewing a speed ball behind
the wheel of a car the police brought
him out Floyd demanded bagged and
screamed to get me out of the car and
put me on the ground he had a cocktail
of of drugs in his system still he
should have been given proper medical
treatment
you know but it's nowhere near what
actually went down Ahmed Aubry is the
most egregious the people who I I know
conservatives who still don't know the
the real story of what happened with
Ahmed Arbury and the McMichaels and
we've had people on the show come on and
be like well the Ahmed Arbury thing that
was Justice I'm like are you kidding did
you even watch that I'm sick of this
Russell Brand in in the corporate press
and in the movies is celebrated oh this
woman went to the police I'm glad she
did if there's evidence that comes out
so be it then Russell Brand should go to
prison if it's true but not police the
Rape Crisis Center okay well then I
don't believe it sorry I I you need
evidence to to convict somebody you know
there's a lot of things people can do
and there's a lot of fake things people
do but my point ultimately
we we have spent all of our time giving
the benefit of the doubt to to so many
different people who are evil at this
point I'm just like you know I don't
know maybe it was 20 years ago you prove
it we have a story if not I I think it's
being used to uh Target Rumble it's
being used to stop Russell Brand from
producing high profile high traffic
anti-establishment media
and that and and they're pushing a
conspiracy theory that the only reason
Russell Brand actually opposes the
establishment is because he was trying
to build web base to protect him from
accusations against them it's psychotic
total BS sorry not I'm not buying it
anyway I think we've uh that horse is is
been beaten to death and we're
continuing to beat it but we'll jump to
this story because I want to show you
the depravity of the establishment
is from NBC News
Standing Ovation for a Ukrainian who
fought with Nazis Sparks anger and an
apology in Canada I'd like to slow down
for you all and just rephrase that
headline NBC News oh how about Canadians
give Standing Ovation to you to Nazi
is that does that does that work for you
guys there you go yaroslav hunka 98 was
recognized by lawmakers shortly after
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
addressed the Canadian Parliament why
are they celebrating a Nazi
this was very hard for me to understand
they said that they brought him there
because he was a Ukrainian and Canadian
hero Canadian hero because he's living
in Canada so he has you know residency
there
but then very quickly said oh we
actually forgot to do a background check
and look him up which if you compare
this to the State of the Union anytime
they're like and tonight with us is Andy
no a journalist like someone has vetted
this person surely that's why they are
they didn't just walk into the chamber
and happen to take a seat right like the
idea that this person was not researched
beforehand either shows that in the
entire Canadian government needs to
consider restaffing or that they were
aware of this but didn't understand the
implications of they don't care I think
Canada does care I think they are just
uh not aware of any sort form of History
I think they are Nazis
you think all of Canada is not to use no
I think I think the people like Trudeau
they they they're Nazis they they learn
to to masquerade and shield their
eugenicist racist policies and cheer for
Nazis
so the big irony here is that the um
the Speaker of the House of Commons uh
uh in the Canadian Parliament so he's
with the the liberal party that's
Trudeau's party uh invited him and uh
the the the Nazi war veteran and
apparently all they had to hear was uh
he he served on a unit that that fought
the USS
USSR but didn't ask for their will on
fighting against him on behalf of who
were fighting on behalf of the Nazis it
was an SS uh unit
and um it's I mean
you know I guess people should remember
that just a year and a half ago the
January 2022 when the Canadian Convoy
protests were happening uh the liberal
government in Trudeau condemned them and
said that they were using Nazi symbolism
and not seen injury and racism and here
they are
um now
um prime minister Trudeau next to
president zielinski in the entire
Parliament giving a standalone Standing
Ovation to not just an accused Nazi or
someone who's accused of being far right
but an actual Nazi veteran yeah
he was a uh uh he served in the 14th
Waffen Grenadier division of the SS a
Nazi military unit whose crimes against
humanity during the Holocaust are well
documented
well there you go Canada I think it's
because they have no understanding of
History right right now Russia is the
big enemy and so anyone who fought
against Russia seems good but they have
very little understanding of actual
World War II history so they don't
understand that they do I I I'm not I'm
not willing to rule out that they do but
I just think a lot of it is someone said
oh this would be a great viral moment
where we stand up for this and they had
no idea because they're just not well
versed okay well you know I'm not going
to give them the benefit out here let's
let's we'll do this okay so they're in
Canada what can I say it's Canadian
right well let's talk about here in the
United States is the political uh what
what political faction is aligned with
the uh with the Canadian government
United States right it's progressives
right I'm not trying it's not a short
question in the United States Trudeau is
would be a progressive he would be
aligned with the left and leftist to a
great degree okay
um our leftists anti-Semitic
no yes there's no that's not a question
you look at black lives matter and their
support uh or I should say many of these
prominent celebrities who supported
black lives matter and also support
Farrakhan and the things he said
unsurprising you look at the article
from tablet magazine about when they
went to the women's March the the
organizers and were pushing anti-semitic
conspiracy theories unsurprising
I just got to be honest
I would not be surprised if eugenicist
anti-semites who share political views
happen to cheer foreignazzi I mean is
that surprising anybody no no you're
like okay so they're eugenicists they
want racial segregation they uh like
what what more are we supposed to argue
here that they use a different word for
whatever it is there okay fine I don't
care call them whatever you want they're
the same thing
it's so funny to me that in a society
where everything is racist or
anti-semitic everybody uh can get
accused of this except for people who
are aligned with supporting Ukraine
including the actual soldiers themselves
oh yeah I mean now Russia goes the other
direction they try and claim that
everything happening is denotification
and I'm like that's stupid too like
Russia is not invading Ukraine because
there's Nazis there because they want
access to Crimea but you know Russia is
now clipping this thing of zelinski
being there and plotting the actual
Affiliated Nazi and being like see we
told you we're here for denotification
it's also the story has also become a
big scandal in Poland because that
particular unit that that
um that elderly man uh was part of was
involved in a lot of slaughtering of a
lot of polls
yep
but they didn't know they didn't vet him
it's an accident that's the stupidest
lie I've ever heard I just like how
could you even pass that off I mean it's
ridiculous I can't say whether or not
they're all anti-semitic and eugenicist
but they're definitely stupid well as I
have to say it's the banality of evil or
it's malicious evil how many of them are
actually maliciously anti-semitic
eugenicists I know probably a few but
they're smart enough to get a bunch of
morons to clap and cheer for a Nazi so
all you need to understand about how
stupid these people are how dangerous
they are is that they don't know or care
who they are clapping and cheering for
it's like when Joe Biden said treat it
on a shot of the pressure and the crack
goes yeah and they're all clapping and
cheering and you're like this is crazy
Joe Biden was on stage and says bad a
calf care and everyone says clapping and
cheering they don't know what he said
uh they just know they're supposed to
clap and so they did
it's frustrating to me that um
often quite uh educated people are
so so they're very good at recognizing
propaganda from Russia and good for them
for that and calling it out but the
propaganda that is coming out from
Ukraine it's like they just there's no
scrutiny of any of it and there's so
much propaganda this whole
but you know there's well one turning a
blind eye to the Contemporary
connections to Nazi organizing in
Ukraine that's completely now no longer
an issue to liberals around the world
um and then Ukraine now being reframed
us as a Bastion of liberal and
Progressive values when it's that's not
reality of what the what that country is
in Northern Society
no I think it's all political theater I
think so much of this is just people not
willing to question your Ukraine in any
any uh instance at all and so you can't
call it any propaganda because you're
not allowed to doubt Ukraine's motives
in anything you're not even allowed to
have any kind of doubt you're supposed
to submit entirely to supporting Ukraine
and never question any of it I mean look
how much money we have shipped over to
Ukraine why because we're just supposed
to and those who do speak out are then
smeared as uh somehow fans of Russia or
fans of
um uh Putin I mean yeah the the smear
tactics just causes people to become
fearful
I think so much of it is just a lack of
understanding of geopolitical History
right they have no idea what the ties
are you know they don't know what
happened in Crimea there's they don't
know what to say they just know right
now it's good to have your blue and
yellow flag out and to agree with
whatever Biden says and therefore
whatever zielinski says yes they want a
simple story of villains and heroes
who's a good uh good guy and who's a bad
guy
and then it leads them to do stupid
mistakes I think it was a genuine
mistake like what happened in the
Canadian Parliament oh a Ukrainian World
War II hero veteran great let's invite
him you know and they stop looking and I
think that's also a testament to the
short attention
span I assume whoever vetted him is
fairly Young working out in a staff
position for this elected official and
they think oh yeah I read most of that
headline and I know what I'm talking
about I don't think it matters I don't
think it matters at all that uh whether
it's a mistake or not that's just it's
at this point in the culture war in this
point in the war with with uh with
Russia and Eastern Europe all that
matters is what they do if we sit around
saying like well you know that was a
mistake every single time they scream
and cheer for Nazis it's like okay
you're gonna be you're gonna be giving
the benefit of the doubt as of to them
the entire way it's like we're sitting
in a car with these people and they're
driving full speed pedal to the metal
foot to the floor right towards a cliff
and we're like well but hold on a minute
they're probably gonna turn right
they're not going to drive off the cliff
they wouldn't do that and then every
single time it's so at this point I'm
just like I don't care what what they
thought they were doing this is what
they do it's who they are that's it so
all I got all I can say is yes Canadian
Parliament gave a standing ovation to a
Nazi yeah but as I said I don't care why
they did it they did it Ukraine has
become so good at playing the West like
if it'll like they're you know one of
their spokespersons now is this
transgender American anymore though oh
that changed I think they got rid of
that person because of uh the trans
spokesperson threatened to kill anyone
you know something like that was that
what happened
I can look it up but there's like a
video where okay well either was or
until very recently this transgender
American spokesperson for Ukrainian
military who doesn't even speak
Ukrainian
um obviously that's you know playing two
Sentiments of the the left in the United
States and then he trains a colony of
the United States and then when Solinski
went to the UN giving a speech and
talking about climate change
all right but listen Ukraine is a colony
of the United States that's why an
American English-speaking leftist is the
one talking about what's going on it
doesn't matter who is in Ukraine the
NATO and the West don't care and when
you learn that the US has been funding
the businesses and everything in Ukraine
might as well consider Ukraine colony of
the United States just call it I I don't
care for this this word play that we
have in modern politics right where it's
just like well you know oh not really we
don't call it that are we at war with
Russia yes
in in all Form and Function but is it
declared when was the last time the US
declared a war against anybody we just
go and do it so you've got U.S citizens
volunteering with U.S weapons with U.S
training with uh with with U.S backed
artillery and intelligence and it's like
but it's Ukraine that's at War yeah
Russia doesn't think so because
practically it's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard and this is where we're
currently at
let me pull up this story here from uh
the New York Times
first Abram's tanks arrive in Ukraine
zielinski says U.S officials said that
an initial batch of 31 M1 Abrams Tanks
promised to Ukraine by the Biden
Administration have been delivered
months ahead of estimates and it's not
just that it's also this 60 Minutes
reported just the other day it was
discovered that the U.S is financing
more than weapons in Ukraine the
government is buying seeds fertilizer
for Farmers paying the salaries of 57
000 First Responders and subsidizing
small businesses I call that a colony
yeah that's it Ukraine is a colony of
the United States
oh just wait I'll I'll count down until
I get the Russell Brand treatment
because I think I think the war machine
is the bigger reason why they're going
after Russell Brand people think it's
it's big Pharma I disagree and it's when
I look I mean 60 Minutes reports this so
maybe they'll go after who who does it
Scott Pelley is that who's doing 60
minutes I think so yeah maybe they'll go
after him he's gonna get accused that'll
be hilarious but uh the United States
your tax dollars are not going so that
Russia could to fight a war in Russia
your tax dollars are propping up small
businesses in Ukraine now ask yourself
why is CBS news reporting this Ukraine
is a colony of the United States which
means we pay for their public uh their
civilian public infrastructure First
Responders it means we subsidize their
small businesses and it means we cover
the cost of Defense that's that's an
American colony as far as I'm concerned
or call it NATO whatever you want but
the US U.S is what's what's paying for
all this I'm surprised that this is
actually being reported because I'm sure
this has been going on for the entire
time we've been sending them money we've
sent them I think 113 billion dollars
there's there's no way people genuinely
thought that was all going to a war
effort
I mean it's funny how they support small
businesses when they're in Ukraine but
on the US you know that's that's the
point I mean the US is in Decay we've
got crime running rampant but geez
that's frustrating isn't it I mean and
now we're supposed to go to the polls
right when we were saying people just
become crazy during election years but
how could you not when you know that you
suffered after everything that happened
during covet the economic turmoil that
small businesses small communities felt
because of this to know that this is how
Joe Biden decided to spend your tax
dollars it can't feel like anything but
a slap in the face worse than that
so how many people lost their businesses
how many people had to shut down their
stores a good job at Walmart and then
you find out that all of your hard work
and the money they took from you is
propping up a small business in Ukraine
that's more than a slap in the face that
that's sedition I mean that that is that
is I I you know you can argue it's not
really treason because treason has
specific parameters but it is something
for the government to take money and
resources from Americans and and who are
suffering and their businesses are
shutting down and send all of that over
to Ukraine for what
it's a complete lack of loyalty to the
American people of any part of the
country it's an occupation of the
American people and an extraction of
their resources to fund other countries
yeah it's like mercantilism in the
reverse was giving to the Colony
or we have an occupying political force
in the United States that's extracting
as much as possible before it implodes
I mean this is one of the reasons that
I'd love to see a Democratic
presidential debate because I'd love to
see Joe Biden number one have to talk
publicly at all but also have to answer
questions about things like this because
so far as long as the Democratic party
can keep it in the background and you
know certain fractions of the media will
talk about it certain people will talk
about it but ultimately the average
voter should know should see the dollar
amount of what is being sent abroad and
where it is going because it's not the
story of just we're helping poor Ukraine
it's being bullied by Russia there is a
much bigger cost and ultimately the
Biden Administration is going to pretend
that that's not happening for as long as
possible as will the Democratic party as
a whole I think the Republicans need to
talk about this in the debate stage as
well because I'm not convinced that if
another Republican not named Donald
Trump gets in there they're going to
stop funding I think it will just
continue yeah I wouldn't be surprised I
think uh if it's Vivek you'll see the
funding stop but Nikki Haley is the
inverse she's screaming with blood
spraying from her mouth that she wants
to block children in foreign countries I
despise that woman by the way these
people are all warmongers they can't
give a rational reasonable justification
for what for what they do what they want
what they're funding they just lie I
think was it Nikki Haley who lied and
said that uh Putin said Poland's next or
something like that yeah I think she
should have started that during the
during the the lesser-known Republican
debate something like that and this and
then and you've got anti-war left and
right being like what is wrong with
these people their their their brains
are not right there is something wrong
you want to make an argument for
intervention and War you can make the
argument you can talk about Russia
aligning with China
the U.S is trying to defend Ukraine and
stop Russia from gaining more resources
in Eastern Europe and expanding their
economic Stranglehold in the region as
they team up with Russia creates a very
big threat so the U.S try to push back I
know all that stuff I've heard all the
arguments but that's not the arguments
they make so long as they want to keep
lying about what they're doing then so
be it they deserve to lose
yeah but will they actually
lose I mean they've lost we had that one
report uh Adrian Norman wrote for
timcast.com uh well and to be fair was
it was um
was it Seymour Hersh I think it was a
report from him that he's speaking with
an intelligence official so Seymour has
reported an intelligent official said oh
it's over Russia won what did Russia
want they wanted the land bridge into
Crimea they got it now what now they
defend it yeah that's it so what what
are we doing there trying to stop them
if if the US's goal really here is to
just strip Russia Russia's access to
Crimea and the Mediterranean then it's
basically just the U.S declaring war on
Russia
no there's no end in sight which also
AIDS divide administration's continues
send money over I mean yeah there is
nothing in this for the American people
and so
I don't understand why we continue it it
costs them every single day and Russia
already has its main objective it
doesn't seem like a productive War but
we're gonna be there uh for as long as
the Democrat is in office and probably a
lot of Republicans too
um
a productive War yeah I think the last
one that we were in yeah so many
productive Wars in history but again
like at a certain point I mean the US
and the EU could say we're going to
broker deal isn't this what Donald Trump
said he said day one I'm gonna stop this
war that would be the first thing I did
the war will stop exactly where it is
exactly and Russia would say okay why is
no one else doing that right like why do
we have to keep doing this
I'm asking such deep questions tonight
on Tim cast IRL I'm stunning all of our
guests
I mean do you guys know anyone who's
like yes this is a great idea let us
continue to send money to Ukraine not at
all no well I think among Democrats it's
still quite a popular position and
certainly in in uh in the EU and in UK
that remains a really popular position
but why what what is their objective
other than we just don't like Russia
well there's this whole apparatus in the
media that does put out the the
propaganda talking points from
Ukraine uh about this being more than
just a war between two Nations a civil
war between Good and Evil and it's it's
I mean it's it's packaged in a way
that's simple for the masses and it
works there's a good side and a bad side
and it's popular uh among Democrats in
the US and uh liberal voters in Canada
and
um liberal people in in Europe but is it
enough to outweigh the economic hardship
that people in the US are facing I mean
we were just talking about gas prices in
LA are crazy
this is your cost of living but also
we're still going to continue to fund
this war abroad it would be impossible
at least in my opinion for anyone who's
reasonable to say that's a good use of
our tax dollars I appreciate this
I think it's just a lot of people aren't
really paying attention to it they just
think it's something that's going on and
that
um that we're kind of supporting it and
it's the current thing but people when
you present the facts to them when you
say hey actually all this money's going
here they would say yeah you know easily
we should stop funding but nobody's
really presenting it to them so they're
not seeing the alternative yeah well
it's a Nuance
um issue and it's it's difficult I think
for the masses to comprehend and to come
up with an informed position it's
similar to the problems that arise from
immigration you know we know what it
does on the labor market what it does uh
how it makes housing crisis worse but
people by and large in urban areas don't
really push back on the policies of
century cities or or U.S immigration
policy in fact in these areas they're
the loudest in saying you know well have
them come in they want their cake and to
eat it too and they don't realize that
the balancing the books actually in the
end doesn't really work you're going to
suffer one way or the other and
um I yeah you know I mean this is really
the responsibility in the press to
present the truth on these issues to the
public but the the establishment Legacy
Media
um fails in that because they're
captured could you think the Legacy
meter would ever go back to having a
standard for truth or do you think it's
a lost lost cause
uh the journalism programs at the the
universities that lead to people going
into New York Times in Washington Post
and other places it's all
I mean these programs have long been
captured I don't I don't really know how
you can at this point do much so what's
the future of Legacy Media in your
opinion
gosh
um
I don't know I think all I mean what I
would like to see happen is
um independent and conservative media
having more support from philanthropists
for one
I mean it's it's really hard to get
Independent Media well-funded you know
riders need to be paid reporters
um need salaries and it's it's a lot of
work it's a lot of money to get that
type of stuff going and we just have to
build up these different institutions I
I guess you know I mean it's a cliche
what I'm saying but really it's it's
it's so important and I think what
causes a lot of
um
conservative or Independent Media to go
under is ultimately it's just the
funding's not there people want to get
their news for free everyone hates going
to a news link and then you have to log
in or you have to pay or something you
know but um that or the experiences
filled with a whole bunch of ads and
that's not pleasant either but it's
unless you're Rumble and then there's no
Burger King ads and the left has more
than enough patrons so they will get
funding from powerful prominent
individuals who want to prop up the
system they'll pay millions of dollars
to websites that can't make a penny and
osoros has funded media as well of
course of course and then on the right
you just got the people who want to
contribute sign up and join and pay what
they can that's about it yeah but I
think there's been enough
stress on the system
and more people are waking up and
starting to join these subscription
programs and make contributions and I
think the Independent Media space is
becoming better at providing real
incentives and and real value to their
members and their customers yeah I was
at um Black Dog Coffee nearby on Friday
and someone came up to me and you know
I've only been on the show for a little
while so it doesn't happen all the time
but he was like Hey I love the work you
guys do and I was like oh gosh thanks so
much and he's like yeah where else am I
supposed to get my news which I found
really interesting it's telling uh
people rely on alternative media in a
way that even a decade ago they couldn't
have and in sort of like the sphere of
influencer marketing it's something no
one could have predicted because it's a
it's a break from the traditional model
built on technology that didn't exist 20
years ago yeah
well let's jump to this story from Tim
guest.com Washington Post downplays Its
Own poll that shows Trump beating Biden
by 10 points the poll found 56 Americans
disapproving of biting take a look at
this I'll just jump right to 538
the last two polls we have from ABC News
and the Washington Post show Trump is up
10 points and nine points I love this
because if you even go back to last week
you do it Biden does have a poll right
here against Trump he's up two but
you've got Trump up three in this one up
five up three it looks like and and what
do we have one of them's big one of
them's got like 6 000 uh morning console
no these are older ones yeah I guess uh
they must change this a lot talking
about this earlier you've got this one
from September September 15th 2500
people Trump's up one point
let's go back here 3 000 registered
voters Harris X Trump is up five yeah so
they they did change this from what I
was reading earlier but uh you can see
basically when it's not Trump when it's
yunken DeSantis when it's Haley uh
actually Haley beats Joe Biden while
surprising
but you can see that Trump's winning
that's it we did not have this in the
2020 cycle so if it would stand to
reason at the election we're held today
Joe Biden loses
yeah but how's he doing in the in the
crucial States though
um uh I I don't know that's a good
question I can say that this poll also
found among Independents Trump is up I
think like 11. so that matters
independent voters matters for the swing
States but the swing States themselves
it's a it's a more important question
individually I think Trump just needs to
win what does he need like Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin or something yeah
good luck
because that's not even a question of
sentiments and a question it's a
question of procedure Trump's going to
need to overcome massive procedural
biases against them with these states
I'm not surprised that these poll
numbers everybody that I talked to they
would take Trump over Biden any day but
I am surprised that the Washington Post
actually released it and that kind of
gives me a little bit concern because
maybe they might start putting these out
to kind of put the narrative in that oh
the Democrats need to replace Joe Biden
because everybody's been talking about
he'll eventually be replaced but we
don't know how it's going to come I
don't see him just stepping down so they
might try to take him out with some sort
of Scandal or maybe they just start
highlighting actual polls and say
actually Biden's not doing too good we
got to get somebody out of there I think
you're totally right I think a lot of it
is the Washington Post uh acknowledging
that at least within their internal
structure there is they are questioning
Joe Biden and this comes right it
coincides with the date that they set
for the DeSantis Newsom debate right so
that's November 30th now we know that
there are people who would like to see a
DeSantis Newsome 2024 uh race that
that's what they ultimately want
I think that they there is no clear way
I mean we've talked about it a fair
amount on the show there's no clear way
for them to just swap out Biden for New
Summit would be sort of a dramatic
production but there is enough
bifurcation within the party that they
they don't know that they actually want
to see Biden there there's another poll
that came out today I think the company
called Harris X that found uh you know
among voters Biden is ahead but Kennedy
is consistently gaining ground uh Robert
of Kennedy Jr is consistently gaining
ground people are interested to him and
then there is a huge portion of Voters
even among registered Democrats uh you
know 16 at least that say that they
would want someone else they aren't
happy with you know Marion Wellington
RFK Jr or Biden but they also
don't know who would be there I mean you
get you see that there is sort of a a
rumbling to see if maybe someone else
would would step up
um I don't know it's crazy I mean RFK Jr
has initially came out I think around
five percent and he's consistently
climbed he I'm seeing him pull
consistently yeah
and I think uh they've just lost control
of the machine right
they can't do anything about it if Biden
was the best they could muster the
screwed
yeah
but they don't have a clear way to
handle getting rid of him and I think
I've always thought it was that Biden
himself wants to stay for as long as
possible why would he want to step down
he's I I in my opinion obviously in ill
health uh and so that's why you would
get his press secretary saying oh well
he's still considering what to do even
when Biden had made statements saying no
I intend to run again uh this went on
for a long time it was sort of strange
and then he sort of rolled out this
video campaign discreetly he announced
to be a video that he was going to run
for a second election or a second term
uh I think it wouldn't be the case if
they really felt he was in a strong
position in terms of his policies and
his health I think that they would
celebrate him as the incumbent if they
if they really believed in him and the
Democratic party doesn't
yeah so there's been more and more
obvious every day it's like there's
eventually going to be a point like Tim
talked about how Newsome comes and saves
uh Biden passing out on stage or
something like that there's going to be
a point where that's going to happen and
it's just going to take like a couple a
couple more polls that are entertained
right that you know for us I guess you
could say us and we would like seeing
Trump ahead of him just a couple more I
think we're like right there I think
we're seeing a repeat of um uh uh who am
I thinking of uh the Supreme Court
Justice who everyone wanted to step down
and then she didn't
um oh uh Vader Ginsburg yes thank you uh
when Ruth Bader Ginsburg was was they
were trying to time it so that a
Democrat could appoint her and there
were a lot of people who said she stayed
too long and then ultimately uh died
when Donald Trump was in office and that
was such a disaster I think in some ways
Biden is going to do the same thing
which is he really should step down and
he said you know all sorts of things
when he was running he made it overtures
as if he would be a one-term president
but he was really sort of here to defeat
Donald Trump and obviously now ego
before everything else he doesn't want
to give up his seat or at least the
powers that have kept him in his don't
want him to go uh I think Trump wins
2024. yeah easily I mean I don't know
about it easily I think there's gonna be
a lot of crazy that happens but I just
think
narratively Trump's gonna win who do you
think is uh
Elon Musk Elon musk's adage right the
most entertaining outcome tends to be is
it what elon's razor or did someone else
come up with that that's someone else's
quote isn't it the most entertaining
outcome tends to be I thought it was
Elon Musk but maybe he's just uh passed
it off I just can't imagine a world in
which we don't get another term of
Donald Trump
I just don't know but like all the
pieces lined up on the chessboard Biden
I mean to be fair a a Biden presidency
is also comical you know what I mean
like at this point in his life seeing
like the president wheeled out to the
podium in a wheelchair with a burlap
with a little blanket on his lap and
he's like and you're like hey you know
spicy it's a comical but costly I don't
know that we could actually do it who do
you think Vice the vice president if who
do you think Trump's gonna pick as a
vice president because I feel like his
vice president's actually going to be
sort of important I mean given
everything Christina yeah
yeah you guys really think that a
republican can can win
in 2024 given how the electoral process
has changed since covid
yes those changes by 42 000 votes
in 2020. yes but in my opinion the way
elections are Iran uh in many states
that systematically disadvantages
Republicans of course it does but Trump
only lost by 42 000 votes the advantage
Democrats had with universal mail and
voting was everyone's locked inside
their homes and they couldn't leave they
don't have that Advantage anymore so
they'll need something and we've had
other elections since since
um November 2020 and it hasn't really
turned out that well for Republicans
because Republicans are only just now
starting to wake up to the issue and
again we're talking about an electoral
system where Trump lost by 40 000 votes
in three states which could easily be
made up versus individual members of
Congress and key districts where we were
like wow we're surprised they did not do
better well yeah I mean in Lauren
bobert's District she came really close
to losing my favorite thing about that
is as soon as she pulled that slightly
her opponent I think fresh was his name
was like no no recount no recount like
what do you mean no no let's let's go
through every single battle with a
fine-tooth comb well I think the issue
is universal mail and voting did play a
role it does benefit Democrats but
demographics shift because of covid that
benefits Democrats but the issue really
comes down to do Democrats have the same
Edge the first time around is Joe Biden
building confidence and we're talking
about one man at a national level and
not individual members of Congress
because what we did see is that you
you're likely you're likely to get and
this happened in 2018 as well if you
were a Democrat but moderate collected
there were 31 moderate Democrats that
were like we don't want to fight with
Trump we want to focus on Health Care
your wages things like that for you guys
you know unions we want to work for you
guys and so they voted for these dudes
that moderate message Works people care
more about kitchen table issues than
they do about anything else
now the issue is with Trump
okay at the local level you know that
you can vote for a Democrat you know the
guy he's got a much you know it's a
smaller uh constituency and maybe you
talk to him and you trust them but
you've known that fouries of Biden has
been really really bad so you're like
you might you'll probably get a lot of
Independence they're going to be like
yeah maybe vote for a Libertarian
Democrat or some middle position but
then vote for Donald Trump for president
because that's the Practical solution
so yes can Donald Trump win yeah he only
lost by 42 000 votes yeah how could he
not win like that's that that's that
that's probably like a million bucks and
spending on ads they could have done to
get Trump those those ballots yeah and I
think in 2020 Trump was kind of looked
at as the villain uh amongst Democrats
and even now uh going into 2024 he's
kind of fondly missed people missed the
days of trump and they're not so angry
at him because they didn't have to deal
with him every day for four years I
don't think it's going to be the same
outcome as 2020. yeah I think there's
also other people that have watched the
outcome of what their their choice was
in The Ballot Box and I've seen what the
result of there's been there's people in
interviews all the time saying I voted
for about unless I'm not going to vote
for him this time and they feel they're
more like Tim always says you say like
would crawl through broken glass through
vote for Trump it's like people yeah
exactly yeah but there are more people
that are like that but I think there's a
lot of people that are just like I ain't
crawling over glass for anybody and I'm
out yeah people people voted against
Trump and all that those things got
worse and now we're at War and they're
probably just like do you think voter
turnout will be particularly
particularly low in 2024 sorry I'm
stuttering today I don't know what how
what was it last time right I thought it
was going to be really high in 2020. I'm
not sure I didn't think it was high it
was high among young people yeah that's
largely because of male and voting right
I think I think it was the uh it was
super high yeah I thought it was going
to be super high and then uh
what do we have here voter turnout in
I mean it's hard it's hard to say
because population growth hmm yeah oh
wait no look at this voter oh this is
percentage of voter turnout this is
amazing in uh let's say 1800 voter
turnout was seven percent
no wait what U.S presidential election
popular vote totals is a percentage of
the total U.S population wow
that is insane
yeah that's yo in in 1912 voter turnout
was under 20 it was 18 17 this looks
like yeah 17 no wait 16 percent
wow
yeah I'm impressed and that's turned out
over total population though 16 of the
US population population voted for the
uh voted
in the presidential election in 1912.
so today we got 50 it's not about man
you look at even during the Civil War
nobody was Voting nobody cared that's
crazy
I mean a lot less people could have
voted too
percentage-wise well I'm just saying
you're saying voting was restricted so I
wonder like what the turnout is well
there you go amongst uh registered
voters right yeah it doubles in 1928.
women love going out to do things that
that looks like that's about it like uh
just shy 20 suffrage happens and it's
just shy of 40 so it looks like it's
slightly more than doubled and now uh
since then it's gone slightly it's been
trending upwards
yeah not this only goes for 2016 by the
way but I'm pretty sure 2020 was the
biggest
81. yeah people are like 81 million
votes were born they were mailing out
balance to people's homes right so it
wasn't turnout it was uh voter
participation yeah
we'll see what happens I think it'll go
down in 2024 actually I'm curious based
on that in California do you see lots of
political signage already like I know in
parts of West Virginia the Trump signs
went up in 2016 and have stayed the
whole time do you see Pro Biden signs
like what are you seeing on the ground
where you live
I can probably say that I have never
seen a pro Biden sign
um even after Biden won some of my
neighbors still had their Trump flags up
the Trump flags and signs were going up
for a while you know kind of in protest
um but I see F Biden shirts or
um let's go Brandon was a lot there's
nobody who's really motivated for Biden
just from what I've seen yeah what was
the um
uh the let's go brand and stuff that
blew up
in wave of not even to technically
pro-trump just anti-vites I tweeted
about this the other day
um it's still kind of an anti-trump
sentiment I was pulling into a parking
lot and I see a guy he's got a sticker
on the back of his car says Trump 2024
my window is down so I was almost gonna
say yo like I see you bro but I get
closer it's Trump 20 to 24 years in
prison
oh
faked you out I wish
right like I know I don't like that guy
uh I find that interesting because I
I've always like lived in more
liberal-leaning areas where if you like
any kind of conservative or libertarian
you tend to keep it to yourself but
every once in a while you'll be
somewhere and you'll see there's one
house on the Block that is like I don't
care I'm putting up my political science
and they're typically 45 pro-trump signs
there's this one house that I pass in
the area that'll have this flag of like
Trump standing over Eagles and like you
know he's like just like a caricature
but there are there's no equivalent for
Joe Biden there is maybe vote Joe Biden
because you like the Democrats but
there's not this same sort of belief in
his capabilities in my opinion and I
think that's just because people voted
for Joe Biden because they wanted to get
Trump out he was he was the anti-trump
guy they weren't necessarily so gung-ho
about Biden they just didn't like Trump
that much that they would vote for Biden
to get Trump out so they're not
incentivized to wave the Biden Flags or
buy some Biden merch in the same way
that pro-trump voters were they're
definitely not super fans they're not
like the Trump base that's for sure
right even like I remember there was a
lot of Obama emerged back in the day and
yeah mad hype Hillary Clinton she had a
bunch of stuff I'm with her H is all
everywhere yeah
um but I mean Dubai's never captured
that attention any of the times he's run
for president no no way if you live in a
neighborhood where
um people feel safe and comfortable to
put up political signage of different
diverse views uh consider yourself quite
fortunate
um coming from Portland Oregon
if you you didn't even if you expressed
any type of dissenting views your
property would be highly likely
subjected to violence or potentially
even serious violence like Austin or
such let me pull the story real quick
just uh put a pin that we have this on
the post-millennial leader in Richmond
Democrat Party group posted bomb threat
against Andy no Virginia talk the post
included an image of dynamite with
Jarvis writing description box on my way
to the Andy no event so you've
experience this stuff I think everyone
knows directly covering the extremism do
you want to elaborate on what you're
talking about
uh well you know we because uh the last
has cultural dominance like and they
they face no sunshine or no
um social consequences for expressing
radical and hateful uh extremist beliefs
they just they're able to push it
further and further to the point where
you can have somebody who's I mean we're
not talking about somebody who's in
Black Block
um antifa type of group this is somebody
who's in a leadership role in the in the
Richmond City Democratic committee which
is the official
um party Democrat Party group in
Richmond Virginia feeling confident and
fine to put this type of posts publicly
um and and going back to what I was just
saying a moment ago
those uh leftists who feel empowered to
go and Destroy people's properties
because they're expressing a different
political view so you know my my heart
is warm just to hear Claire just talk
briefly about you know the different
type of political science that she's
seen in places Sheila's don't take that
for granted if you're an American who
lives in one of those places consider
yourself lucky because there are places
like Portland Seattle obviously
different boroughs of New York where you
you are potentially put yourself in your
family at risk for expressing a
mainstream political view
well and they had that guy whose biker
neighbor went and lit his uh Trump sign
on fire I mean there are places that
people do feel entitled to uh well there
were neighbors though the guy that kind
of I just meant that he biked in the
area
um I I think it's interesting one of the
things that you're saying reminds me of
um in your book you talked about how
people uh especially Progressive groups
will travel to small towns and set up
coffee shops or or bookstores and sort
of become very visible in that sense and
that becomes sort of how they begin to
have influence and control areas so
there are times that people are
expressing their views because they're
relying on the tolerance and the the
community's ability to welcome them even
if they don't agree with them and then
they become sort of a destructive force
in and of themselves
oh yeah yeah we see this phenomenon all
the time people who
um who adhere to certain principle
tolerance and then the other side gains
power and that that uh is not
reciprocated back onto them and they
suffer as a result I mean conservatives
experience that a lot right we want to
welcome and protect all views of
expression but then you have those who
are calling for an overturning of the
entire system and a totalitarian system
where people are subject to violence
potentially or deaths for their views
and and I mean I'm not saying that's
manifested in real life necessarily
anywhere in the US but in there's
certain Pockets where those type of
sentiments are Salient to a population
and they're able to
um cause so much violence
and and destruction on those around them
and and those in the victims just have
no ability to counter
um in uh so so I was speaking in
Richmond because Richmond is a city that
um
has experience uh over the years a
really radical cultural shift to the
left I think a lot of that has to do
with the university there the Virginia
Commonwealth University they had months
of riots uh in 2020 like Portland and a
lot of the same parallels uh between
Portland and Virginia I I documented in
explored in the speech you have
um
so elected local officials the mayor of
those on city council condoning
um the riots
um even going out to some of those
protests turned riots to participate and
give them support
um you have police whose ability to
um actually enforce the law is curtailed
by the local politicians and then you
have outside agitators coming in and
without a lot of money and it just
creates I mean a lot of destabilization
I think I think one of the questions one
of the questions I was asked when I
spoke on Friday was like could this
happen again and I say well yes
obviously because the the same the
networks that were strengthened and
established in 2020 are not only still
there they're stronger now and there
might be a bit of protests and Riot
fatigue today but just give it a bit of
time and there will be some other George
Floyd type moment that it's caught on
video
um clipped exploited and blasted on
social media and it'll get people to the
streets well 2024 is around the corner
it is it is about that time yeah right
2020 BLM George Floyd election year 2024
this next summer but Richmond doesn't
have any more monuments to pull down
what is it going to do it could be
literally anywhere and the issue is the
media lies
so let's say um let's let's say
something like this 2024 and there's
like some dude working in his garage in
the suburbs of I don't know some let's
say Youngstown Ohio is in his garage and
then uh some dude sneaks into his garage
and say grabs a a power tool case a
couple hundred bucks and then runs for
it and this guy's been known to the
neighborhood so the dude calls the
police the guy's neighbor confronts the
guy and like stop grabs him and stops
them and they fight over the tool and
then the the dude who is stealing it you
know falls on hits his head and dies
the medial report that two white men
approached a man who was walking down
the street a black man and they
mercilessly beat him to death and then
you'll get your riots and then a month
later the video will be released from
their ring security camera showing the
guy robbing the house and it'll be just
like Ahmed Aubry and they will find any
story they can to create a racially
charged atmosphere that will result in
riots and then they'll use that to claim
racism or whatever and then the people
who are correctly calling out this story
does not you know follow that line
they'll say aha they're racist this
prove it don't vote for Republicans etc
etc yeah did you guys see the story it
was kind of inverse to that of course it
didn't get coverage because the victim
was white but I guess
um these two black dudes pulled up to a
basketball court and they got into a
fight with the white guy black dude hits
the white guy and white guy falls on his
head dies they went to trial uh beat an
involuntary manslaughter charge and were
only convicted of assault there you go
it's ridiculous yeah I saw that yep
what's gonna happen with 2024 is they
don't need there to be an actual
instance of
like racism or violence the media will
just make it up garage Paul rope it's a
noose well Trump being a the Republican
nominee would just that would get people
out on the streets I mean in 26 2015 and
in early 2016 that was such a powerful
propaganda coup for antifo because you
know before their their messaging
extremist messaging has come comes out
through their pamphlets and texts and
their blogs which reaches a smaller
audience with Trump being the nominee at
that time then now because the entire
liberal media establishment saying the
exact same prop talking points uh uh
America might elect to fascists and then
after the election America did elect his
death camps are around the corner last
deportations around the corners I mean
this sounds crazy as they say it now but
look back on the opinion pieces and
headlines that were published in the
paper as a record those were the type of
sentiments that they were putting out
you know brainwash a lot of useful
idiots on the left to go out and be much
more accepting of political violence on
their side
I don't know why or how this happened
but I feel like amongst my generation
and the younger Generations coming up
political violence and vitriol is just
so high and it really rubbed me the
wrong way to see that people aren't even
accepting of just opposing beliefs it's
either my way or the highway you're evil
if you're evil I can go after you and
hurt you because I am the good guy I
wanna I wanna highlight this I I saw
this from Jack besobic but uh I just
just verified the Articles here's an
article from Slate November 19 2015.
Donald Trump is actually a moderate
Republican that's why he's winning
November 19th 2015 and then on November
25th 2015 Donald Trump is a fascist now
hold on the original article Donald
Trump is a moderate written by Jamel
Bowie and the second article written by
Jamel Bowie the same dude a week later
he wrote Trump as a moderates wise
winning then he wrote Trump is a fascist
why they are evil there is no legitimate
reason why a sane person would say I'm
gonna write an article calling Trump a
moderate and then a week later be like
I'm gonna write it out oh no oh I just
discovered he's actually a fascist no
what happened was
everybody was going after Trump
so this person probably thought if I
write that he's a moderate I bet I get a
ton of traffic from people who are going
to be like what what do you mean how how
and then a week later okay been there
done that I'm gonna write Drums of
fascists and get a million more views
welcome to the media yeah I think you're
right it's it's part of the click bait
they need you to be so shocked by the
things they're saying and at these
points that they're putting out there uh
I I find the story around Donald Trump
to be completely personality based I bet
most people can't really distinguish
anything about his political platforms
or I should clarify most people who are
identifying as Progressive journalists
they they don't know the nuances of
differences between Republicans they
just know that Trump does things they
don't like and they don't like him the
most and so therefore whatever they have
to say to make him the bad guy uh it is
weird there are times when you'll see
sort of more left-leaning Outlets almost
praise other Republicans to make Donald
Trump look bad when there's sort of no
informed opinion other than they aren't
Trump so therefore they're whatever
they're doing is okay
but this type of disinfo that causes
hysteria and panic is so dangerous but I
mean when you ingrain into let's say 50
of the population that that
um this uh Republican front runner is is
a fascist then that label then is
applied obviously to people who would
vote for him and those who support for
him and then what what what do good
moral people do against fascists well we
want to bash them and it normalizes that
type of acceptance of political violence
I'm speaking unfortunately as somebody
who's been a victim of the violence of
antifa because of these labels that have
been applied to me and then I mean with
my the event that I just spoke at in
Richmond the script that was going out
to these different venues that that
canceled and took the third venue to
meet out should be able to speak people
would just call in and say things like
you have a Neo-Nazi who's speaking there
are armed neo-nazis who are coming this
event goes forward people could actually
die and people in corporate PRS or just
freak out they're like okay well they'll
cancel it and that that's the danger I
think of you know we can laugh at this
and look back and because I think we're
all of us here at sustainable or
grounded but there are actually so many
people even highly educated perhaps it's
the most educative who are vulnerable to
this type of Hysteria and this info but
I you know we I take it so seriously and
I
um I'm so angry at how
um
slothily people use these labels of like
fascists and like dictator and all these
type of terms as as if it's like okay to
just throw it around apparently now you
know people just do that with like
Reckless abandon and it's like you you
know people who
um instill that into their beliefs like
actually take take up weapons and like
maim and like kill people and not belief
that happened in Portland with a a
self-described anti-phone number who
shot dad a trump supporter because he
really thought this guy was this white
supremacist fashion it's just murdered
him in downtown yep so
you were saying before that you felt
like the younger Generations are sort of
fueled by this political device so they
won't listen to other people and it it
makes sense because they're completely
surrounded by it uh there's no escape
and there's no accuracy in reporting
yeah that's true that's true
I I always wonder if there is going to
be a reckoning at which at what point
you know we have
maybe Margaret Taylor Greene
green couple a year ago or so and uh
someone who's at the table said oh I'd
actually never listen to anything but
Random clips of you and hearing you talk
it definitely changed my opinion or it
gave me an Insight uh and I I find this
really interesting because I think there
are so many people who aren't exposed to
anyone but other people who are
similarly afraid of these labels of
fascists and you know anyone who's
brushed by these words are obviously out
to get them and so there was a natural
it almost makes sense resistance to it
you you don't want to be affiliated with
them but if the if you're completely
right if the labels are are misused then
their fear and their willingness to
maybe react violently is based on
inaccurate information during the Trump
years I would always try to reach out to
the other aisle just because it was like
uh it was it was a Hot Topic you know
and I would always hear from people wow
you're actually the first Trump
supporter I've talked to which is crazy
because how have you ignored half of the
country you you've just been so
tight-knit in your bubble that you
haven't even thought of you know what
let me check out the other side I used
to be a Democrat back in the day and
then when I was uh coming of voting age
I said to myself I'm gonna make an
informed decision I will check out both
the right and the left and I just found
that the right made more sense to me and
I wish more people would do that what
made you want to do that though because
I think it is unusual I think young
people tend to be like oh that's what my
how my family votes it's not my friends
vote the thing that made me want to do
that was intro to logic I took that my
first year in college and I learned how
to critically think and this was also
around the time where BLM first wave was
popping off and I didn't like how they
kind of wanted to make black people the
victim so much so that was rubbing me
the wrong way and then I took intro to
logic and I said let me think
objectively rather than subjectively let
me go outside my bubble let me see
what's on both sides and then the right
made more sense for me yeah
I think people don't want to be able to
either bubble I think I think and and
conservatives are guilty of this too
that we shouldn't you know pretend
otherwise but some people just want to
be told the way they see the world is
completely correct they want to have all
their biases confirmed always but I
think that's
what's really dividing the the left and
the right the culture war is no longer
politics I think it's obvious to
anybody's been watching a show like this
for a long time it is simply are you
someone who is an independently minded
person or are you someone who is
terrified of being shunned
Democrats basically just March in
lockstep with whatever acceptable
opinion is whatever popular thing
currently is and it changes and catches
people off guard and they get yelled at
and they apologize and they freak out
the reason why they'll get so
irrationally angry at the idea of you
defending Donald Trump is because they
know they know you're right
when when they when the media lies about
Donald Trump and then you say well you
know Trump never did that they'll start
yelling at you why are you defending him
why the reason they're getting angry is
because they're like uh oh I'm gonna get
ostracized I will get targeted if you
keep talking like this I've got a show
that I'm I'm against him I'm not one of
you yeah that kind of it's like they
realize what they've been doing for so
long and they realize they can turn
against them you know it's like when uh
was it was it David Hogg said he was
going to keep wearing masks even though
they got rid of the mandates because he
didn't want someone to think he was a
republican yeah they are so terrified of
being the out group so what happens is
it doesn't matter if your pro-life
pro-choice
it matters are you in the cult or not
you can be in the cult and you can be
someone like you know Adam kinzinger Liz
Cheney or Joe Walsh they are obvious
cult members It's the funniest thing to
see Democrats have a high approval
rating for George W bush so long as you
are part of the machine cult the
cathedral you know there you go do you
guys think people on the right or
um
a bit too loose in in their accusations
of their political opponents of being
communists and socialists no you don't
no
why so there is uh as we've been talking
about this quite a bit over the past
couple weeks the banality of evil and
malicious evil or you know as I go even
further say abject evil so how did the
Nazis how are they able to pull off what
they pulled off where did we hear this I
think someone's talking about it here on
the show maybe that there was a group of
uh regular guys that were conscripted in
World War II and when they were they
became police officers and when they
were ordered to just start you know
gunning down and rounding up Jewish
people for the concentration caps
without question they just did as they
were told Michael malice often says that
there is uh I I don't know I don't know
I can't say the exact quote I'll
paraphrase but something the effect of
there is no crime so egregious that
police would not carry it out if ordered
to up in uh including up to and
including the murder of children I
certainly think that would be the that
would be the case if they were
instructed to do so as we saw in Lina
when uh we have all these missing
children and people are saying that they
were in the cars trapped and the police
were blocking the exit to Lahaina so
that people were trapped into Road and
they were burning to death and then some
of these people jumped out of their cars
and jumped into the water while the cops
held the road closed because they don't
care now did those officers wake up and
decide that they were going to go murder
a bunch of people of course not
they were stupid people who did not care
for the responsibilities of their job
who were told don't let anyone leave
town not explicitly but they said shut
this road down and they went you got it
and so while the fires were burning
people to death they were cops like
don't care
so when it comes to the accusations of
the right
on the line on the right uh yeah from
from the right about the left then uh
that's what I meant by on the right
they're making these accusations
I don't think it's uh incorrect to say
that they're Communists did every single
communist in the Soviet Union who
supported the system or participate in
it know that they were Communists did
they read literature on Marx or they're
just doing as they were told
they were just doing they was they were
told it was the commonplace ignorance
that led to these evil actions so you
have high profile individuals like uh
people in the Fulton County DA's office
charging Donald Trump they're evil you
have the people in New York City that
are filing these lawsuits falsely
accusing Trump of things or trying to
charge him on these these these BS
charges you've got the documents case
against them all of this is complete
garbage nonsense you have the Democrats
who in 2016 claimed falsely that Russia
manipulated the election to help Donald
Trump win and Trump was illegitimate
then 2020 comes around and when when the
opponents of Biden start saying similar
things about fraud they say you're all
crazy Psychopaths Etc et cetera they are
a combination of all things evil
powerful interest at the top who say
things like can't we just drone this guy
in reference to Julian Assange in London
Hillary Clinton is evil but then you
have the blind ignorant followers so if
you have high profile activists who
raise hundreds of millions of dollars
who say that they are marxists
explicitly that's black lives matter and
then you have people Marching In the
Street throwing up the red salute in
support of overt communism they're
Communists yeah they don't have to sit
there and and put their hand on the on
the Bible of of of Marx
dos capital and things like that they
just need to be cogs in the machine that
actively support the issue of Communism
and then you have people breaking free
from that saying I don't want to be
involved and that's fine they can but
for the time being if BLM is coming out
saying they're trained marxists and then
I see videos of Millennials and gen Z
doing the red salute
oh brother Communists like if you saw a
17 year old kid marching around Goose
stepping and doing a Roman salute you'd
be like he's a Nazi yeah oh well hold on
did he actually read mineconf does he
actually no come on dude wait we don't
we don't play those games so the issue
now is high profile activists to the
tunes of millions of dollars buying
property having the slogans so
ubiquitous that Amazon and Walmart use
them like okay yeah they're they're
they're in the style of Chinese
communism they are authoritarian call
them whatever you want they adhere to a
to some kind of marxist ideology likely
as a means of manipulating I think it's
probably better to call them
neo-fascists or something like this a
lot of people call them neo-marxist but
I'm like I don't think they actually
believe what Marx believed they're using
Marxist ideas to manipulate stupid
people and into being controlled so it's
something else
neophishistic maybe whatever but call
them whatever you want to call them
Marxist Communists it applies to all of
them yeah and you can and you can wake
up one day and be like oh that was bad
that I was doing that there's a guy who
I retweeted a while ago he was a doctor
and he tweeted that he was completely
wrong about the lockdowns and he
apologizes the data was bad and he
regrets where he was and I'm like see
there you go you know somebody who says
whoa I can't believe what I was doing
yeah and you can really do that in One
Direction you know from the left corner
to the right you can't do it from the
you hear me from the left or you can
read it from the right going to the left
I don't think the left would just never
have you no they do they they have their
their I I think it's all fake the people
were like you know what I was a trump
supporter and then I realized they were
like no you didn't that's a lie that's
not true because the the far right as as
defined by the media and the
establishment includes Libertarians who
hate Donald Trump yeah true so it's like
somebody who was you know I'm sure there
are people who have been blue pilled who
have been manipulated and tricked into
believing lies from the machine but you
have to be really insane or really
broken to read
facts about how the media lied which
brings you to Donald Trump and then be
like yeah but then I started reading
more of the of of NBC News and really
just decided not to fact check it it's
like that simple I'll give you an
example barisma is the best example
especially with everything's going on
there's no circumstance in which you can
unlearn the barisma Scandal and if you
go and say I don't support Trump you
know Biden's the guy for me go into a
circle of Democrats and say oh yeah but
you know about Victor shoken right when
he signed the sworn affidavit saying
Biden got him fired they're going to be
like you're a Nazi you're far right get
out yeah for who it was you were talking
to bro you read that from the show about
that and had knew nothing about it I
can't remember who it was now well
that's Brianna Wu yeah that's right
that's right it was Hunter Avalon they
have no idea the stuff happened or
they're lying and saying they didn't
know that it happened but the reality is
the people who are like you know I was a
trump supporter and now I'm not okay
maybe you are a trump supporter because
you are living under a rock and your
neighbor said he was voting for Trump so
he said sure but you're certainly not
someone who pays attention
what's your take do you think that
people are inaccurate when they
criticize the left as being communists
um well if Tim is specifically talking
about the militant activists who use
those symbols that are associated with
Communism well clearly those those are
out
um labels for them I just you know I I
cringe often when I just when I see
people on the right very kind of loosely
just calling random or large swaths of
the political opposition just you know
they're all these are all just all
Communists or even using the term
fascists as well it's just uh the one's
true and one's not language is so
important and meaning in the definitions
of words is important
um I just you know I think playing the
same game of what the left does of just
you know their disregard of how they who
they call fascists or who they call far
right whatever I think the right should
be very careful or not to mirror that in
the same way unfortunately maybe that I
think that's so that boat has already
sailed but why shouldn't they mirror it
are you implying that they're only
saying it because it was said of them
yes and it's it's about sort of like
just this rhetorical claim of like okay
you call us you know you're so loosest
word uh fascist on our side where we're
just gonna call all of you oh that's not
what's happening it is a fact that
they're Communists it is not a fact some
of them but they but right so you're
defining communist as someone who is a
learned red communist as opposed to the
banality of Communism not even
necessarily learn it they could just I
mean somebody who's just finds appeal in
the basic tenets of Communism if a guy
is uh puts on a black hoodie and runs
around with antifa smashing they see a
communist
not necessarily he might identify as a
militant Anarchist that's a big part of
the antivirus but that's but that's not
Anarchy Anarchy meaning without
Authority right so they can call
themselves whatever they want I don't
care that's not true
anarchists are not violent
right
well if the far left there are examples
in in 20th century European history of
you know Anna's ideologues have carried
out assassinations
and other types of violence so I would I
would argue the core of the of the
phrase without Authority
would displace a person from the use of
violence and someone who wants to claim
they're an anarchist who then engages in
say throwing dynamite in a market or
something like that they're not an
anarchist that's an authoritarian action
Anarchy is quite literally the word and
without arche Authority anybody who
believes that there is no authority of
the system one could make the
philosophical argument that they're
trying to strip Authority from the
system that's why they're an anarchist
that's not correct in most and most
Anarchist philosophy that's why you'll
find among Libertarians and what people
refer to as right anarchists the
non-aggression principle if you use
violence against another person it's an
assertion of your authority over them
which defies itself what what is
actually happening is if you look at the
anarchist communities they have
inherently tanky authoritarian views on
how to run Society then they just say
but I'm an anarchist sure like dude just
because you're stupid doesn't mean
you're not a communist if they believe
Marxist ideology utilize that Al G2 and
and utilize violence to that and they're
not anarchists they are someone who
believes in an authority believes in a
system believes that it should be done
the way they want it done and that they
are the ones who have the the right to
use cause of death to get that that's
not Anarchy so this is the issue that
we've always had going back to Occupy
Wall Street when these dudes would dress
up in all black and people would call
them the anarchists and stuff and we
would colloquy colloquial colloquially
say it sometimes but being friends with
a bunch of anarchists especially with
like Ron Paul Ron Paul Revolution only a
few years before we were like that's not
Anarchy running around smashing windows
and beating people up because they don't
agree with you is quite literally what
anarchists are opposed to when you when
you argue that the police for instance
were doing something wrong and they were
abusing people or saying the street was
frozen you couldn't go there it was an
arbitrary excess of authority over
people that was ill-gotten it was it was
it was it was false
when people start putting on hoodies and
masks a uniform going around saying do
what we say or we will physically strike
you I was like identical to the police
and they would go that's so stupid we
are not I'm like bro two guys who are
part of groups that dress the same and
assert their Authority whether it's
warranted or not
but but this is just the no true
Scotsman argument no it's not it's it's
the it's the if someone comes to you and
says they're a thing does it mean they
are a thing no it does not words Define
things so if someone comes to you and
they're clearly a white blonde guy and
they say actually I'm a black guy from
Nigeria you're gonna be like you're
actually a white guy right within
political philosophies if there if there
is a a faction that identifies within
this larger political ideology and they
carry out actions that
um in the name of this ideology I don't
think we should necessarily just say
well
they're not acting truly in in for this
particular cause I you know I I get into
there are a lot of
um women's rights activists who actually
really disagree with the work I do
because I I particularly talk about how
a lot of these women's rights events
it's antifa trantifa Communists and and
socialists and violent far left coming
up to attack these women who are
speaking out about trans ideology well a
lot of these women who are speaking out
are old school leftists who say no no no
no these people they're not leftists
they're not on our side they have
nothing to do with us they're they're
regressive they they're not they're not
on the same side as us and I think that
type of denial
um
it's it it's not reflective of the
reality that the on the ground
manifestation of political philosophy
does change over time you're not going
to have necessarily a peer manifestation
every time but it's still part of that
and I think there you know I think
within the wider Anarchist Community you
Anarchist need to start asking
themselves a bit more if they're not
doing already why are some of the most
prominent anarchists we see doing the
direct action on the street are the
militant antifungal because they're not
anarchists
you like your position comes from the if
a person declares themselves to be they
are that I disagree if a communist came
out and said don't worry I'm not a
communist am I going to be like well
hold on guys they're not a communist
he's like he's he's wearing a a you know
a a blue jumpsuit with a little Kami hat
on holding Das Capitol and waving a
communist flag is I am not a communist I
say okay he's not
he said he's not so he's not right
that's that's illogical
well that's not what I'm saying and you
know you can have
people can pick and
um uh cherry pick whatever
aspects of different texts or historical
figures who may represent that political
ideology and draw inspiration from it
and say that that is you know that
they're part of a longer tradition it's
just
all right
and I I just got frustrated when there's
like uh so the so the issue right now is
not recognizing a problem on one own
side which I see the left does but the
right is wrong to call them Communists
so Libertarians conservatives
evangelicals post-liberals
non-politically Affiliated people
comprise the far right all of those
people I just described this disparate
group of people who completely disagree
with each other and will actually yell
at each other in arguments are called
one group fascists all of them
that's nonsensical and incorrect you get
a Libertarian you get Dave Smith in here
and he will tell you why he does not
like Donald Trump
they will but the media and the
Democrats will still claim he's a trump
supporter and there was a famous moment
where he was on Fox News and they were
like you know with Donald Trump he's
like I don't care I don't like Donald
Trump he's a Libertarian they can't
differentiate everyone's a fascist
meanwhile the bulk and actually this was
there was a data point we we brought up
a couple years ago
it showed the cluster of political
affiliation a voting block based on
social political social and economic
views
so it was it was a it was a uh uh
two-dimensional Grid or yeah
two-dimensional is a square
showing mapping out where you stand
socially socially Progressive or
conservative and economically
Progressive or conservative Trump's
voting base was spread all the way
across the economic spectrum but more
socially conservative and the entire
Democrat voting base was clustered in
one tight-packed corner of socially and
economically Progressive they all exist
mostly in the same space so we say
typically they tend to be Communists I
don't care what they call themselves I'm
identifying them I don't care what they
say
they say we believe in Marxist ideas we
believe in critical race Theory critical
gender Theory we believe in in critical
class Theory and I'm like okay these are
communist ideas they then say they want
massive multinational corporations and
centralized authoritarian power from the
government to start arresting and
locking up their political opponents
while they celebrate and clap for it you
then have more militant factions like
antifa Etc who will privately say or on
on you know a personal level they'll say
well I don't like Joe Biden or the
machine ever either but I will fight on
their behalf for example when Trump
supporters were outside of a hospital
protesting masks antifa showed up and
beat the crap out of him why are they
defending a government decree because
they're communists they support the
government doing what it wants under
this leftist ethos of class gender and
race oppression
that's the bulk of the voting base in it
graphed out and before us they then call
all of us fascists despite the fact that
Libertarians and fascists are arguing
with each other so you can't just look
at it and be like it is stupid that the
right calls the left communist because
the left calls the right fascist but
that's not what's happening it is one
side is evil one side is not evil why
I'm not saying people on the right are
good I'm saying whatever the right is
it's a disparate group of people it is
various different ideologies and
factions having a discussion on why
wokeness and the establishment machine
is bad and the things that and calling
out the lies from the mainstream media
the left overwhelming overwhelmingly
marches in lockstep with whatever the
LIE happens to be even though it changes
from from time to time sometimes as
quickly as a day we mix in women with an
X was the unoffensive thing and then a
day later it was offensive because it
was exclusionary this is why they can't
define words like woman there is nothing
to it and this is a really great example
of it you can find people who are
pro-life pro-progressive tax you can
find people like Jimmy Dore who want
Universal Health Care but their right
wing or fascist that makes no sense so
that's clearly a false determination but
then you can look at the at the left and
not a single one of them defines the
word woman and if they do they use some
nonsensical like we had Lance on the
show he said woman is an adult human
female and trans women are female it's
like okay you see there's no logic there
they're Marching In lockstep but we
gotta go to super chats so we can we can
we'll carry on that conversation or
whatever my my diatribe in the members
only section but we'll read super chats
for now now
and hear what you all have to say
because I'm sure everybody's super
chatting saying I'm wrong
which is which is always welcome so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only show coming
up in about 20 minutes but for now we
will read what you all have to say it's
always welcome but you could skip their
super chats
we have Bertman who says Palmdale come
back to me
that's crisper oh he got 661 in the
building he got the first chat
congratulations yeah I'm not your buddy
guy says I love how Trudeau just blamed
Russian propaganda for our Senate giving
multiple standing ovations to an actual
Nazi who was part of the SS
wow Trudeau says don't look or question
me when I do it
yeah rules for the waffle Sensei says I
really wish Rumble would have literally
said pound sand tyrants in their letter
back to the UK government missed
opportunity
oh I think they did it I think they did
right you know it was it was polite it
was a polite I'm sure Rumble doesn't
want to burn Bridges you know it's it's
one thing if they're being aggressive
later but Russell doesn't want to
potentially be shut out completely
Shane Wilder says watch watch the
presser from Eagle Pass today I think
rep Tony Gonzalez was spot on what he
said quote we have to stop waiting on
President Biden to solve this issue now
to see if the Republican can do it
yeah look I think the it Biden's not
solving the issue
this is part of the plan
there's a video of CBP I believe it's
CBP opening a gate at the border and
letting people in and Counting them they
are being instructed to open the Border
that's it
so anybody acting like you know why
won't why won't they get the job done
because they they this is this is their
plan
that's it yeah
carry on
OMG puppy says with Rumble this is
someone demonstrating their power
someone like MI6 they won't accept
losing
I think it's it seems fairly routine to
be honest like oh hey we got an upstart
big Tech uh or upstart social media
company that's got a high profile
celebrity who's speaking out against the
Ukraine war shut them down yeah
there you go
bear in mind says I miss seeing you in
my notifications that's right yeah and
soon today yep no notifications pop up
if you if you like the show that's why I
say share the show because probably the
only reason the show still exists is
because you guys share it did people
used to get notifications or was it from
the beginning
this week but today no notification at
all my phone it depends too so you don't
appear on the trending Channel or
trending page but you should right oh
that's the funny thing too when we put
out um the song only ever wanted on
timcast music we were trending on
YouTube I think we were trending in the
top 10 or something like that and then
uh or maybe it's not 20. and then we put
out the song genocide once again we were
trending and I was like look at that
like our song right next to like post
Malone that's crazy but we were getting
substantially less views we got a couple
hundred thousand views and we were
trending and I'm like
Tim cast iron should be trending every
single night yeah we get a couple
hundred thousand views in like an hour
or two hours yeah based on those numbers
yep nope there's no there's no other
explanation for it doesn't make any
sense if if
you know I'm sure their argument is if
they allowed timcast IRL to behave
normally in the trend section same as
every video every night Tim cast would
be a trending video yeah which would
exponentially increase the amount of
viewers we get the amount of subscribers
we get and then we'd be bigger than Mr
Beast they do not want that to happen so
they suppress that's it yeah that's true
but if every single person who watched
every single time shared this show then
we would be bigger I take a lot of work
and uh you know it is what it is all
right let's grab some more we got Dallas
Smith says yo Andy good to see you doing
well I had fun working as a security
during the Portland riots let me know if
you need me again when you're in town
God bless
what was the username for that Dallas
Smith huh no it doesn't go back through
your emails and see if you have a
connection it's cool that people who
work security for you you know follow
your work actually yeah it's not just a
job for them they really like you there
have been some uh kind people who
volunteer in their time because you know
private security is really expensive and
back then
um
yeah yeah that's cool
all right what do we got we got uh sa
federally says this is the best podcast
in history but every single time Tim
refers to Quad City Style Pizza as
Chicago style pizza he appropriates my
culture the west side of Illinois is the
best side of Illinois I am not saying
you don't have the same kind of pizza
I'm saying real Chicago pizza is not
deep dish in Chicago we eat Quad City
Style Pizza there you have me that's my
point people go to Chicago and they're
like I want Chicago pizza and they're
like right this way to the circus they
go they bring you to a pizza place
people from Chicago don't go to you're
saying deep dish pizza is a tourist trap
yeah it's great you know uh Lou
Malnati's is really really good we used
to have a place I don't know if it still
exists called Leona's and that was
really awesome because they like a
cornbread crust deep dish awesome whoa
yeah it was really good really good yeah
crumbly and delicious and uh Giordano's
of course is very famous everybody
orders this stuff there's uh Unos but uh
if you are a if you grew up in Chicago
with a neighborhood pizza place it was
like a flat bread square cut Pizza
is this like I don't know if this is
true or not but people who are from
Chicago like really from Chicago like
the White Sox but then people who moved
to Chicago like the Cubs
I don't know in my experience if you're
on the North side you're a Cubs fan from
the South Side you were a socks fan okay
it's regional I don't know anything
about that well you have to be honest
but it was like yeah it's a Crosstown
Classic it's the you know north south
rivalry it was like you know everyone's
like you're on the South Side so you're
supposed to be Cubs fans I'm like I
don't know my parents were from the
North side or something uh we went to
Cubs games well the best pizza in
America is in New England so go check it
out but the thing is at the time growing
up the socks were good and the cups were
losing so
it's like a cup I remember going to a
Cubs game with my family we left right
away because they were losing so
miserably yeah and then I remember when
the White Sox won the World Series and
uh it was insane in Chicago just like
people were crashing cars and screaming
and it went insane that's nuts and then
when the Cubs won the World Series there
was like nothing happened every
everybody because it wasn't in Chicago I
guess uh makes a big difference I guess
but everybody was surrounding Wrigley
Stadium while they're playing you know I
forgot what they're playing where
they're playing Cleveland or something
and then uh once it ended everyone
cheered for the Cubs finally having won
after like 100 years or whatever
everyone just walked to the train I
think someone broke a window but then
they got yelled at and the cops came and
arrested him or something like that was
it I was just walking they're like and
there was like well I guess nobody's
drinking they're hanging out outside if
the if people were at if if they
happened at the Cubs Stadium if the game
was actually there when they won you
would have hordes of drunk people losing
their minds yeah it would have been nuts
the crazy thing about uh
Wrigleyville was that if you got up at
like four or five in the morning right
at the crack of dawn and just walk down
Clark Street you'd probably find a
couple wallets money in them
you know from personal experience yeah
absolutely I lived I lived off of uh off
of Clark and you've got what a couple
thousand drunk people every night just
partying and so you wake up there's
money lying around and there's wallets
just like on the ground like iPhones too
at this point at this point yeah back
then we didn't we I didn't uh when was I
down there that was like 2008 or nine so
not a whole lot of iPhones back then but
you know people had them no like I'd
walk down the street and you'd you'd
easily find five ten bucks and change if
you were just walking down the street
and then you go buy breakfast super easy
way to live to be honest all right where
we at
what is this uh let's grab Damien
Simmons says well I will be buying stock
in Rumble now not Financial advice just
showing my support for Dan bongino just
got four more shares GameStop this
yeah so I I have shares and I bought
chairs and Rumble a little while ago
because uh I believe in the platform but
uh I probably won't buy any more because
I know the CEO and like and Tim cast
uses uh Rumble Affiliated companies and
infrastructure so you know I don't like
stock trading stuff and I would not want
to be smirched my good name in the way
Nancy Pelosi's bismirches her bad name
but uh for everybody else
I would not make any recommendations
other than to say I'm seeing a lot of
people talk about how they want to buy
Rumble stock Rumble stock went down
a little bit today and it's like it's
down from where it started but that's
always to be expected when a company uh
goes public but uh it's funny because
according to the Motley Fool
Chris pavlovsky the CEO is a billionaire
yeah
wow I was like is that true so based on
the amount of shares he have has and the
value of the shares currently his net
worth should be just around a billion
dollars okay yeah
what do you do with it you can't sell it
yeah
all right
Falcon Legend says Andy do you believe
Robert Silverman who's done smears on
you and Tim when he tweeted that he was
just joking about being the leader of
Brooklyn antifa
seems like a weird joke to be like oh I
was just kidding it was a performance
piece I guess I don't know who this
person is I don't recall commenting uh
about this individual so I don't
uh I think you're right for like The
Daily Beast or something
yeah it's a research get back to us yeah
all right where are we at
Danny Miller says thanks for covering
the shameful Canadian Applause for a
World War II veteran who fought against
Russia oh wait wasn't Russia an ally in
World War II how times change yeah isn't
that crazy yeah that's what I'm saying
they have no understanding of History so
they think modern day standards apply in
the sense that Russia is a bad guy now
so they must have always been the bad
guy but that's not the case
Zachary Zachary am not says Tim I'm
learning how to play guitar I would love
it if you would put the chords to play
your song will of the people uh let me
think what are the chords that I do I
think it is
I think it's e alternating between uh e
and B
and then it goes down to G and G flat
so if you play e g g flat
or is it is it F sharp F Sharps poly
more accurate way of describing it yeah
F sharp yeah yeah
depends on who you ask a guess but yeah
so
no no no no no no it's not it's B
it's b g
F sharp there you go congratulations
there's other chords in the song but
that's the gist of it that's like the
verse yeah I'm sure Carter writes from
tabs after that and put it online tabs
yeah I love tabs I'm learning how to
play bass with those tabs yeah yeah I
hope you learn
Laura Spade says I was already
boycotting Burger King over the whole
milk shark situation I believe that was
when they went on Twitter talking about
milkshakes being against Andy know or
something was it was that burger
McDonald's
I don't recall either one of those I
think Burger King
yeah after after the thing happened with
milkshakes there was a comment made by
some like Burger King account you want
to look that up I'm looking it up yeah
it was like when like Wendy's and Burger
King were all trying to be like these
meme accounts Wendy's was the only good
one though you know right yeah they were
really good actually yeah corporate
family friendly how do you pull it off
I'm not finding anything right now but
I'll keep digging was it Burger King it
might have been working I don't think
lore Spade is wrong hmm
Jeremy Paul says reach out to Chris from
the to be better podcast he would be a
great addition to the culture War he's
smart and libertarian leaning I say the
best role model for young men in dating
culture interesting we'll take a look
never heard of that
red rumax says Colonel Kurtz today had
one of Russell's lovers on her Channel
testifying he is a great guy she was
also begging you to have her on your
channel regarding M Manson Marilyn
Manson yeah Marilyn Manson so wait
someone dated Marilyn Manson and Russell
Brand
that's a crazy resume
it didn't say that she was dating
Marilyn Manson I'm sorry about that
sorry that was incorrect one of
Russell's lovers and also wanted to talk
about Marilyn Manson uh
is it fair to say that Russell Brand is
the UK's Joe Rogan
is that sort of like the level that they
would be trying to go after hit on I
don't know I I mean maybe the UK is
substantially smaller right like
proportional to the size of their media
obviously we're the more dominant media
culture but but no it's probably not I
mean look Joe Rogan he can make a video
where he's like yo I saw a dog and then
boom headlines like Joe Rogan tells dog
story or everywhere it's like what calm
down man yeah I think it's funny when
Joe Rogan has an opinion it becomes
major news and I'll see it like reported
by everybody and I'm like jeez man like
Joe Rogan questions you know progressive
tax being implemented in in you know
Cook County and then it's just like what
yeah see these stories pop up where it's
just like whatever he makes an opinion
because so many people are listening to
him that's that's what I kind of wonder
about with Russell Brand if people who
don't consider themselves political
listen to him and therefore he's even
more dangerous because he's a wider
reach than just one Fringe political
commentator
we'll grab some more Super chats the
risk says first time tip chatting name
the Halloween coffee rise or die with
Roberto Jr by the way love Appalachian
nights and Rise of the Birdo Jr sleepy
Joe for decaf Rock on
we are launching re-rise with Roberto Jr
and uh we've already we've been working
on our blend so our signature our
signature coffees are always some kind
of you know blend combination that we
try to find the right flavor and
um for re-rise with Roberto Jr limited
edition
it is a chicken foot bursting out of the
Grave because as much as we love Roberto
Jr we're also crass but uh that one I
think is going to be out just in time
for Halloween hopefully and I think we
wanted to do an initial we wanted we
wanted to do only 500 but it's
impossible
it has to be at least five thousand so
we're like okay well we'll figure it out
maybe maybe we'll be a single run of
5000 for the season and then when it's
gone it's gone
um just to Circle back to the Burger
King thing I'm John pasaki uh there
there was a tweet from Burger King after
uh
milk tape was thrown at Nigel farage I
think oh that's what it was and they got
banned because they were saying like
this is a great idea I can't find the
Tweet because it got banned but it was
after Nigel farage was thrown the Burger
King corporate account was like
yeah totally right being like we're
funny and we're very good with the memes
and farage was before you right correct
yeah because it was like they started
doing this milkshaking thing and then
with you they got really violent yes
beat me on that so I feel bad that
during this this uh
um Super Chat thing and the questions
directed at me and a lot of it it's like
I don't remember I don't recall that and
I that might be part of the I mean it's
one of probably the lingering um effects
of the the uh subrock mode um brain
hemorrhage that I wow suffered in 2019
2019 is not beating people just think
that I was just hit with like drinks but
like something but it was much more
dangerous well it was the the punches in
in kicks to my body and bashes to my
head and eyes and face it was then after
that that they threw all the liquids on
it and I
um so I had traumatic brain injury and
memory issues part of that so apologize
to any of the viewers out there who you
know are hearing a lot of me like saying
I I don't recall I don't know what this
is about but yes I do remember the
Burger King UK account making light of
what happened to Nigel they tweeted May
18th of 2019 dear people of Scotland
were selling milkshakes all weekend have
fun love BK hashtag just saying yeah and
that was right after it happened yep
let's grab more Arthur Palmer says the
biggest problem with the media is that
they saw often scream wolf when there
are none no one will trust to cry until
a wolf bites someone an F yeah Joseph
says exception Tim not the rule I know
18 year old leftists and they are
wonderful people just lied to constantly
explain it with them we aren't different
I never said you can't talk to the
banality of Communism and you can
explain to people and people wake up in
fact said the opposite said many people
do wake up and they realize like holy
crap what I was doing was wrong and I
shouldn't be party to this my point is
that if there is a group of people
marching down the street smashing
Windows waving a communist flag
organized by a group that's called
revolutionary communism and then you
meet a guy who's in there and be like
well I'm not and it's like okay but
listen
that's fine I get that but that's what I
would refer to as the banality of evil
you are facilitating Communists and
their expansion and institutional
capture so
your group you are you are communists
it's like there's a dude it's just I
don't know I I don't I don't see any
other point to say it any other way to
get into nitty-gritty of like well it is
it is revcom they are revolutionary
Communists but some of the people who
are working for them in support of
Communism don't actually know their
Communists so I won't call them that
it's like well that's confusing and hard
to describe to people what's really
going on you know I think there's this
expectation from people on the right
that we should be principled or holier
than thou and not to adopt the left
tactics but I think we should do away
with that because as deranged as the
left tactics are they're effective but
I'm not even saying that I'm saying the
left is lying about people on the right
being fascists because they are evil and
the people on the right are calling them
Communists accurately
so it's more of the left using the
olinsky tactics accuse your opponents of
doing what you do isn't one of the
tactics to label your opponent's Nazis
uh yes right attack was fascists exactly
attack him as fascist so so you you will
have a Libertarian and a trump supporter
having an argument we we will have two
different conservatives in here arguing
over the war in Ukraine like you know we
had Omni hordes and Matt Gates having a
a a a principled and heated discussion
on the merits and Matt gate said you
sound like John McCain and Ami was like
that sounds like a compliment and it's
like right it's like very different
World Views but they're both fascists
even though Matt's like no International
War it makes no sense fascism that makes
no sense none but we'll every more we'll
get some more super jets in
where are we at
all right grandstanding and hot dogging
says if Russell Brand was trying to
Shield himself from his past Behavior he
would not be building an
anti-establishment audience he would be
acting like Howard Stern and Catering to
the woke mob keep up the great work guys
exactly Howard Stern is a good example
of someone who is scared of being metude
how many how much you want to bet yeah
Howard Stern if there was anybody I had
to make a guess it would not be I if you
put Russell Brandon Howard Stern in
front of me and said which one do you
think is more likely to have Abused
Women I'm pointing Howard Stern I'm like
didn't he do it on his show right yeah
like didn't they have something like
launching hot dogs at women's tits or
something like that I mean they had so
much stuff on that show man I don't know
I could be wrong I want to be careful
here but I'm just like I thought it was
there was some conversation he was
having with um
was it Hilary Duff or some like former
young Starlet that people years later
were like oh wow wait a minute maybe
this is not okay I mean if that's the
first thing things at surface what else
has been buried and a lot of people who
are in these positions you know instead
of going in the media people who have
allegations against them will go to them
with a lawyer and they'll privately
settle about it so we'll potentially
never hear about these things because
they've reached some some sort of
agreement in in hopes of getting out
ahead of it or keeping it from getting
into the media
yeah I mean like if if you look at
Russell Brand I just I just Google
searched it and it's like a compilation
of Howard Stern abusing women and if you
look at the stuff Russell Brand was
doing the accusing of it's like he's
making crude jokes on TV that are like
inappropriate and it's like wow you know
those the people were laughing they
liked that dark comedy you look at the
stuff Howard Stern is doing he's
legitimately like saying things to these
women that are just like
oh yeah it's way way different yeah he's
not joking he's literally asking them
about their bodies and stuff and they're
getting uncomfortable and it's like not
to mention the stuff he said about
Columbine like holy yeah yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have that
uncensored members only show coming up
for you in about a minute or two and of
course we'll be taking your calls as
members so sign up for timcast join the
Discord because the members at
timcast.com are building culture and
they would like to be friends with you
too they do an after show they do uh
they do a pre-show and after dark after
show so definitely sign up and as a as a
member in the Discord you can submit
questions and even call into the show
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Patriot J do you want to shout anything
out yes I got some Alpha jerky here
this is good stuff Tim knows it's good
oh he was eating it before BS yeah it's
just meat pepper you can use the code
big 15 you'll get 15 off uh you can
follow me on Twitter at patriotj I'm on
Instagram as well if you need legal
services in the County of Los Angeles or
greater areas give me a holler uh new
music coming next year yeah that's it
thanks for having me ingredients beef
pepper salt look at that it's so good
big 15. that's the code there you go and
you want to shout anything out yes uh
first thank you Tim
um you can follow me on X at Mr Andy NGO
and my website is andy.ngo.com please
support my independent journalism thank
you now it's been fun having you both
here I love that you can do legal
services and music so great and it's
always nice to see you Andy uh I'm
Hannah Claire brimwell I'm a writer for
timcast.com you should follow at
timcastnews on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best in my opinion although I
am a fan of post-millennial of course if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Twitter at uh Hannah Claire no I'm on
Twitter at HC brimlow and I'm on
Instagram at hannahclar.b thank you guys
so much and serge is back yes I am it's
good to be back uh pleasure to meet you
Andy I've been watching you for a while
we're talking about before the show a
little bit here likewise yeah and uh
yeah and also pleasure to meet you as
well I've seen some of your stuff uh
Chris has talked about you in the past I
think before I remember Chris Bertman is
your number one fan yeah
man we got that Antelope Valley
connection love Chris yeah uh yeah but
I'm search.com on uh X Etc uh you know
what I always say let's argue it's fun
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about a minute
thanks for hanging out